so yeah my name my name is jakub I am a
physicist by training which and I work
on data analysis and software
development for the experiment means I'm
a Python Python and C++ programmer by
necessity so I'll start by telling you
all about so that's me I'm where I work
so you see you sound a little daisy logo
on my introductory slide and Daisy you
might know is the national particle
physics lab in Germany the main campus
is in hum book there is actually not
many people know this but there's a
branch campus here not quite in Berlin
but just outside so down here so we're
over here at this blue dot of daisies
way down here at this little pin on the
banks of the dhamma river this is the
astrophysics division of day of day Z so
this is a Helmholtz research center that
means anything to you we have about 200
scientists postdocs and students and
when we work on there primarily is high
energy astrophysics with gamma rays
which is the main focus and there's a
small part doing it with neutrinos so
the experiments we hosted that we
participate in there are ice cube which
would I work on a satellite-based gamma
ray telescope called Fermi which may
have heard of and then a series of
ground-based gamma-ray telescopes magic
which is on la palma s which is in
Namibian desert and the cherenkov
telescope array which is a future
project which would be the mother of all
gamma-ray telescopes which is in
development and Daisy's one of the lead
institutes on that so so that's that's
Daisy the experimental work on is
actually not just Daisy it's an
international collaboration spread out
over the entire world I'm pretty much
mostly North America and northern Europe
about 40 institutions about 300 people
total and it's headquartered in Madison
Wisconsin the experiment itself though
is at the South Pole which is very far
from here so the experiment is called so
the full name is the ice cube South Pole
neutrino Observatory it's a lot of words
and what I'm going to try to do is
unpack that for you as a motivation
before I actually get into what my talk
is supposed to be about which is the
data pipeline that we use to do science
all right so first
we're gonna start from the middle and
sort of work our way out to the ends so
first what is a neutrino in the first
place so we're going to talk about
particle physics now it'll be over from
the soon I promise so you may know about
electrons fairly common thing the
electron is a point-like particle
corresponding to the electron so a
related particle is the neutrino which
is like an electron also point-like also
has the same spin properties but is much
much lighter it has mass but I'm very
very little it's at least a million
times less massive than the electron and
it carries no charge which means it
participates only in the so-called weak
interaction which creative naming it's
very weak and just like there are three
generations of things that are likely
elect when there's oh the electron has
heavier older brothers or have your
unstable brothers the muon and tau
they're also corresponding neutrinos now
the thing that makes neutrino is
interesting apart from their fundamental
weirdness is the sorts of things that
make them and how we can use those to
study the underlying processes so one of
the way these were actually proposed and
then discovered so the thing that gave
the motivation for them is radioactive
decay is a certain kind called beta
decay which changes the char the the
charge of a nucleus that proceeds by
emitting a neutrino similarly there's
also a fusion in declare reactors it's a
big source of neutrinos the Sun is
actually a quite bright in neutrinos if
you hold up your thumbnail which is
about a square centimeter there are a
hundred billion solar neutrinos
streaming through it every moment but
since they interact so weakly they
almost never actually deposit energy in
your thumbnail or anywhere in your body
more than a couple times in your
lifetime so those are all fairly low
energies would go higher in energy we
can also make these in particle
accelerators like the LHC at CERN in
Geneva Switzerland we can go up by about
a factor of a thousand there but the
really high energy ones are going to
come from the natural accelerators that
exist somewhere in our universe and
those are going to be even more powerful
in that we're going to go we're going to
go up by three orders of by several
orders of magnitude here and so
what we're looking for is we're looking
for neutrinos from cosmic accelerators
and the reason so we're actually trying
to learn by that and the way we know
that these cosmic accelerators
accelerators exist is because of
something called the cosmic rays and so
cosmic rays are atomic nuclei of char
smaller charged particles that are
bombarding the earth from all directions
constantly this is actually the reason
why the radioactive the rate of
radioactivity so of radiation the
experience of it actually increases as
you go up in altitude so when you're on
a plane into at 30,000 feet to actually
being irradiated much more than you're
here on the ground the fact was actually
discovered here in Berlin almost 100
years ago by a guy who took balloon
flights up with a little radiometer and
saw the count rate went up and first
discovered the cosmic rays 100 years
later we know that those come from all
directions and that their energies
extend quite far this is there's
something out there that is accelerating
single protons really macroscopic
energies there's a plot here on the left
which is a aspect and energy spectrum
and the units on the bottom are the EV
electron volts which are you things we
usually use to measure chemical energy
so the end so like the energy that an
electron emits when it jumps between
orbitals and Adam and this is a log
scale it's going to quite far go to the
numbers like 10 to the 19 and that's
once you get in was like 10 to 19 that
is a jewel which is a macroscopic amount
of energy that's a kilogram meter
squared per second squared that's if you
take like a ball and roll it across the
floor that's a sort of energy you're
going to kinetic energy going to have
and something is putting that kind of
energy into a single proton and that's
that's wild we don't know what does that
or where those are because those things
are charged as they're making their way
to us their directions get smeared out
by magnetic fields in the galaxy between
galaxies and if you look at the sky in
college in cosmic rays you don't
actually see like points stars you see
just this overall smearing and this is
the scale on this on this plot on the
right is a part is a two-tenths of a
percent so they're really really nice
atomic now associated with those though
there should be production of neutrinos
and the same
horses that make those cosmic rays and
since neutrinos are only interact weekly
they're not charged that means that they
don't care about magnetic fields they
travel in straight lines all the time
and nothing basically nothing can stop
them dust and gas and radiation fields
in the in in the way that are in the way
they just they just don't care they go
straight through so they're streaming
through us all the time and it would be
very interesting to go detect them and
see where they point to see what see how
many of them there are but the very
special place we go to look for them is
actually the South Pole and the reason
that is is so if you go to you see the
picture of the globe at the bottom
there's Antarctica The Forgotten seventh
continent about 1,500 kilometres from
the coast is actual geographic South
Pole which has been continuous that
there's been there's been a research
base there since nineteen continuously
man since nineteen fifty-seven a year
and you're out and so right these days
it's actually quite comfortable down
there and we have this nice elevated
station that houses 150 people in the
summertime you fly there on this
military transport plane but the reason
that this is an interesting place to be
is because of what it's sitting on top
of the the South Pole is cell so the
station is a quite high altitude 28
hundred meters pressure-wise is even
higher pressure is about 600 mil abarnes
the air is quite thin but most of that
is actually just ice so the bedrock
itself is almost at sea level and the
rest of this is ice that's been
deposited over hundreds of thousands of
years just by basically ice crystals
precipitating out of the atmosphere and
then layering and layering and layering
and being slowly compressed and what you
have here is a really thick ice sheet
that's almost almost 2,100 meters thick
and is about the clearest ice is much
clearer than any ice that you ever see
up here like the ice cubes you would
take out of your freezer there are very
few bubbles in it there's very little
dust like and travel for hundreds of
meters in this ice without stopping and
so the reason that that it that is
interesting is that you can take it you
can take this ice which is a naturally
occurring medium
and you can use it save a large target
mass that will collect lots of so that
will look like lots of minute lots of
neutrinos and you can use that target
mass for free if you just instrumented
and so about a little over kilometre
from the mat from the main station which
is over here there is the ice cube
experiment and it is the outline of this
is this dotted line in the middle there
is the ice cube lab which is our data
center and so what was done is to melt
holes in the ice that it go a kilometer
and a half or two and a half kilometers
down and to lower sensors into them
light sensors basically pixels of a
super-fast camera and what that gives
you is the detector we call ice cube and
so this is a sketch of it so on the
surface here there is the gayest cube
lab and then there's a kilometer and a
half of hole and then the bottom
kilometer is instrumented with these
things called digital optical modules
which is a pressure sphere the
photomultiplier tube in it and what that
ends up being is a silver just a single
pixel very fast camera can see single
photons and it can resolve their the
time which they arrive to within a
couple of nanoseconds and the reason
that's interesting is because when
neutrinos interact they deposit energy
that energy is going to go into charged
particles with those charged particles
are traveling faster than the sieve and
the local speed of light that charges
shoving electrons in the medium out of
the way and they can't get out of the
way fast enough and so you end up with
basically a sonic boom in light it's
called the cherenkov effect and this
might if you've ever seen a photo of a
reactor cooling pool this eerie blue
light that comes out that's what you're
seeing is this chair golf light and so
there's this bow shock in front and you
can use it we can pick up those photons
and use that to tell where the neutrino
came from and how much energy it had
those sorts of things alright so that's
the experiment and now I'm going to talk
a little bit about how how we handle
data in this experiment and use that to
find neutrinos so this is what our data
pipeline looks like the most one of the
things that's different from every other
data pipeline that you will probably
ever see is that
there's this dividing line here the
dotted line here which divides us into
parts that happen at the South Pole
where communication is very limited
power is very expensive and things that
happen offline in data centers in the
North that we can power with cheap
electricity and then we can actually go
in and fix so in this so in this
pipeline first we have to acquire the
data and then calculate features on that
data and select it down so as almost the
data we fo that we collect is actually
backgrounds understand events so we need
to cook that down to an event the to a
sample it's mostly made of neutrino
events to do our data analysis at the
same time which is also a little
different from from applications that we
hear about here we need to the questions
we want to answer our questions about
the underlying properties other two
years that we're seeing and since we
don't actually have a high-energy
neutrino source we can't we don't have
one of these cosmic accelerators that we
can just put anywhere in the universe
and flip it on and off to tell us what
it should look like in our data so we
actually have to simulate our detector
which is very computationally expensive
so you have to in a computer model the
process of of how a neutrino interacts
and how it dumps energy into the ice and
how that energy gets turned into photons
that we can see and then we take those
events and we've passed those simulate
events the same pipeline so then you
have a set of real data and simulated
data that you can then put through your
data analysis and the end get out
science so one of the main challenges
here is as I said getting actually
getting the data out of the South Pole
getting it process to a form and doing
an initial selection where it will
actually fit over our satellite link
then also simulate generating the
simulated data it's also computationally
expensive and require some coordination
and I mentioned before that this is this
data is then fed to an international
collaboration it has a lot of people in
it not all of whom are so not all of
whom have exactly the same interest this
isn't all going into one into one
monolithic analysis that only has one
results there are probably about 15 or
20 distinct science topics and the
people working on those are not
necessarily experts in data processing
or
they should be experts in that analysis
by the time they the time we finish but
they should not you shouldn't expect
them to be to be experts in the in the
processing and feature extraction before
they get there and so we need to allow
them to configure these this this
processing pipeline and to extend it for
their own work with a minimum of effort
and without out all the way hit hard for
them to blow their own legs off and then
the end is part of that actually
distributing the data to the downstream
analyzers all right so I've talked about
a lot about our data or data our data
what is our data so this is what our
data looks like this is this is a
neutrino event and so what you see here
this is a 3d rendering actually a lot of
water back and forth this is actually in
Python but what you see here these
vertical lines are our so-called strings
of ice cubes this is a cable that hosts
60 of these single pixel detectors and
between these is 125 meters so this is
actually quite big what you're looking
at here and in this event coming from
the left which you don't see is a is a
neutrino and it there's none other than
that nothing's happening around it it
interacts somewhere here in the middle
and then creates a particle called a
muon which is as I said before the
heavier brother of the electron because
so heavy it's very penetrating it
doesn't stop very quickly to see it
gives you a long track at the detector
and what our data look like each one of
these dots here represents one of these
Dom's one of these pixels the color of
that dot did denotes the time which was
detected which is on the color scale
here on the bottom so this whole thing
is we're looking at six microseconds in
time and the size is the number of
photons that it saw and so from this
data you can tell that since there was
nothing nothing over here on the left
side here that that was that that was a
neutrino and that from the pattern of
hits here a lot as it goes out you can
reconstruct the direction and from the
amount of from the amount of light
collected you can infer the
energy that's what a nice event looks
like that is that's the end product what
we're getting it from is data looks like
this it's kind of messy so this is just
this is not a this is a longer view of
the Tekra this is we're just what if you
just read the detector out for ten
milliseconds is what it would look like
it's just lit up like a Christmas tree
for every neutrino we see there are
actually a million background events
which are penetrating muons created in
cosmic ray era showers that so these
muons actually energetic enough to make
it down from the surface and then our
detector and that's not really what we
want those aren't most interesting thing
and even once you've cut out that first
factor of a million there are you're
still not there most of the neutrinos
you see then or fairly low energy also
not terribly interesting and the the red
ones you're really the most interesting
ones are actually quite rare are there
only about ten of those a year and so if
you want to if you want to make that
down selection from 100 billion events a
year to 10 then we need some really
wrote we need some framework for
calculating features on the data in an
efficient way and south so we're going
to talk about next which is the future
calculation and the data selection so
let's try to make this a little more
data science ii calling a feature
calculation we call it usually just
reconstruction alright so we have a
framework for this that the that is
maintained by a core group of about five
to ten five to ten volunteers and we
call it ice tray because you put ice
cubes in an ice tray haha the core of
this is in c++ there's about 20,000
lines in the core if you add the data
clive you add the data storage classes
and a lot of the algorithms that are
then supplied as modules then that goes
up to 80 to a hundred thousand depending
on which distribution now you're using
now the corazon c++ way back when so
before 2008 we used to require users to
write C++ to use this um that was not
great one of the best things that were
that was done at that time was to take a
hello to take the
python library and use that to expose to
right right python bindings for almost
the entire suite so you don't ever have
to you don't even have to know this is
written in c++ to use it which is quite
nice that so that's man that's made
things very easy and there's also
heavily this year uses boost quite
heavily once we do now with C++ 1114
that's less necessary since basically
what happened with single + + 11 and
some of the language keywords were added
and then they imported all boost into
the standard library so things have
gotten much better who's this mention
this morning so there are two main
components this framework one is the
data container which you call an i three
frame different from the pandas
dataframe predates it so this is a
container for an event data for all the
data relating to one event and so that
is the thing that as the object that's
passed back and forth on this framework
and the things that do the passing back
and forth we call I three modules
different from python modules a lot of
name overloading here what that is a
single unit basically similar to this is
basically like processes pipes in UNIX
this manipulate cytherea takes I through
frames does something to them and pass
them to its output and all of our data
storage is done in files because of the
way we're distributed across the globe
it's not really feasible to Disick all
this in databases and still have it be
available at the level it needs to be
for analyzers to work efficiently across
continents and different time zones
alright so the i3 frame is basically
just a dictionary and dictionary of c++
objects that are immutable so you can
keep a pointer to this and be confident
that no one's going to change it under
your feet and they're all related to a
single event and so as I mentioned
before there python bindings and so to
read one of these you just you pop it
out of the out of the out of the file
and then you get this an example event
there are objects that are related to
say the geometry or the pulses which are
the the photon records and then you can
take those and calculate derived
quantities on them our file format is
just you take this frame
and then you serialize it and you don't
put two discs it's just a stream and
contain one or one or more frames and
this is all backed with the boost
serialization library and that gives us
know below and save operations in
particular in contrast to something like
like pickle you get object versioning so
you're allowed to change bill how to
update your classes and then be able to
read old versions and upgrade them away
at a later time so you get backwards
compatibility which is kind of nice but
not for its compatibility because you
don't know what you're going to do in
the future so then so that's a data
container the interface for manipulating
these are our three modules there's just
a single this is a processing stage that
does ideally one thing and does it well
and to configure processing chain you do
this in Python and you just you just
string these things together they're
like they're like building blocks they
don't need to know about each other's
implementation details and all you have
to do is configure them with appropriate
keywords the things either these what
these allowed to do is relatively
restricted they can add things to the
frame they can remove them and or they
can just decide to drop the frame
entirely and that's how you do filtering
just drop them out of the processing
chain and it's fairly compact you make
this tray this tray object and then you
add things to it a typical script here
just has a reader at the beginning and
then a writer to write it out and
something in the middle and then that's
a configuration and the actual inner
loop isn't that execute method we also
since we are really into exposing things
in Python we allow new modules to be
written in Python so this is actually
just a rat this is this I straight out I
three conditional module here is an
instance of boost python class that
allows you to extend that when you call
into this from the c plus plus side it
actually drops into the Python
interpreter execute the code and then
returns the results appropriately cast
to the expected return type and so you
can write something really simple where
you add parameters and you get them and
then you do things to each frame
and one thing this is a lot of seduced
is this is a pretty brain-dead example
but it's allowed us to really prototype
rapidly in Python and sometimes that
carries a performance penalty to this is
a tight loop and looping is expensive in
a dynamic language like Python then you
can rewrite it and c++ if you need to
and especially with with physicist code
physicist tend to write code that just
works and not really worry about whether
it's nice or not and this allows you to
add some sort of enforced prototyping
stage you have to rewrite it if it if
you want it to be fast at some point and
that's it force a little bit of
discipline which is nice so then so the
phils I said so that first stage of
filtering happens at the South Pole the
detector is read out 3,000 times a
second each the average size of an event
of these events data payloads about 4
kilobytes and so it works so we're
excited generating about a terabyte a
day the South Pole is only there is that
there is no there's no fiber running to
the pole there's only a satellite link
and since it's at the South Pole
geostationary orbits orbits work really
terribly at the South Pole and so the
satellites will use for communication
aren't visible all the day there are
there up on average about six hours and
so we have relatively small bandwidth
allocation about a hundred gigabytes a
day and so we filter out ninety percent
of our data before even there before
even send it north and that fills our
bandwidth allocation that all goes to a
giant a data warehouse which is a large
luster cluster in Madison Wisconsin
that's we know of for petabytes and
Counting as we just accumulate data not
all that is actual experiment data
though there is also simulation so I'm
not going to say much about it except
that it's very computationally expensive
and just mentioned how we do grid
computing as opposed to cluster
computing so in the academic world we
don't tend to rent space from google or
amazon since our accounting departments
really don't like unpredictable pricing
but we have no we have computing farms
that we own and also there are
collaborations with institutions in
europe and the u.s. opportunistic you
each other's clusters and so those are
scheduled with us where the system
called HC Condor and what that basically
gives you is the ability to run a
process on some sort of Linux flavor
will know what it is when you get there
but it's usually a red hot variant and
also a system for provisioning your
experiment software on a read-only file
system that has lots of caching layers
and is fairly robust alright so once
we've done the processing that then
Simon will move on to the actual
analysis so this I three frame that I
mentioned is very flexible that's the
idea we don't want to we don't we want
the we want to skate basically this this
game out to be able to change from event
to event but once you're actually ready
for your analysis and that's not the
most efficient thing in particular since
this is just a giant map of irregular
data reading one filled out of each
event can be very inefficient and so
we'd rather have for that or tabular
formats it's we also a framework one
things I contributed for turning this
irregular data for hammering it into a
tabular form that you can read into your
favorite analysis tool as an array and
do things with and so phrase for each
type there is a specific converter that
does the coercion and maybe some
reduction and summarizing and puts that
an abstract data structure there's just
this general table row and then we have
format specific backends since of course
we don't all use the same tools there is
people who come more from the
accelerator community more from the real
high energy physics use this tool kit
called root which is a thing that was
provided by CERN and lives its own
little world and is orthogonal to us to
the rest of computing and there's I
guess sort of a generational thing a lot
of people like Python and there so we
write this out to HD of five tables and
those can go into I'll be right in with
pie tables very nicely or with pandas
through pie tables or h 5 pi a lot of
different things all right so the actual
analysis is usually act is much less
exciting than a than the data processing
it turns out so the procedure for most
analyses is actually kind of yeah kind
of bland so the usually it's done with
bindi
you know and does a lot more than
happens in other fields that the you
make it you fill the data into a
histogram and then the histogram
basically is the data that's what you do
your analysis on and the reason we do
that is because it's really it's really
easy to understand when you're writing
this up in a paper how you how you got
to the statistics you can just predict
you can predict the mean in each bin I'm
fairly in a fairly straightforward way
and then calculate statistics on that in
a way that's easy to explain and that
makes it easy easy to get papers
accepted in the community and the
disadvantage that you have to actually
choose the binning and especially of
small amounts of data then that that's a
choice they can bias it and the way we
usually get around that is to or isolate
ourselves from that bias is to develop
these analyses without actually looking
at the experimental data and actually do
it blind and only know what the data
looks like once we've fixed all the
parameters like the bending choice a
little advertisement since histograms
are very important or much more
important to us than they are to the
rest the community we have developed
some custom tools one of this is a
little package called dashi it was
developed by a grad student soybean has
been adopted by a lot of people in an
ice cube and so this is basically
instead of having just this histogram
function like a numpy you actually have
an object that internally does its
actual binning with it with the
histogram function but also has a lot of
handy tools built in like you can tell
you what it's mean is and you can
manipulate you can add them together you
can slice them you can project them and
you can also store them later sometimes
if you have hundreds of millions of
points to fill into a histogram you
don't have to refill that every time and
so you can store them hdf5 files as
shown here and it's it's on github all
right so as an example there was the
paper that was published in in 2013
which was the thing that I sku so far
best known for which is the actual
discovery the first evidence that we
that these asset these high energy
astrophysical neutrinos I've been
talking about actually exist before that
they're just type of
pickle so this actually use a very
simple event selection there was no
machine learning involved unfortunately
other ones do but in this case you can
actually get away without it so just two
features you set out you set a threshold
a number of photons which is in a number
of large number and that takes that one
hundred billion events down to 20 to
only a million and then you demand that
the hit pattern actually starts inside
the detector which is I thing that only
neutrinos can do and once you do that
you end up with only 28 events left and
then the question that was asked for
this this analysis is a really simple
one which is so there are these
high-energy events they look a lot like
the Astrophysical but they could just be
a fluctuation of data and the thing
tooks good the fluctuation of the
background and the thing to exclude is
that they are just a fluctuation is the
question you ask is what it is so we
have these 28 events they had fairly
high energies what is the chance of
there a fluctuation and quite literally
the thing the thing that is done is to
take these data so here all the data
points plotted in energy and angle and
tube in though fill those into
two-dimensional histogram and then
compare the accounts and the bins of
that histogram to the predicted mean
from simulation using a poisson
likelihood and then calculate the test
statistic and and ask how often that
should arise by chance and the answer
luckily is that that how that happens
less than one in every 22 million trials
and so that's what we call 5 Sigma to
discovery and we went and published that
in this paper here okay so in so i told
you about now I think I'm almost out of
time but that about ice cube which is a
cubic kilometer detector at the South
Pole that uses neutrinos to look into
the universe and that we are very happy
users of Python in our processing and
our data analysis and with that I will
take questions
thank you yucko questions
who's your isp in the South Pole so our
isp is the Antarctic support Kandra is
it's it's actually Lockheed Martin it's
a yeah I'm not going to say anything
about them because it's probably being
recorded so yeah it's that security is
very security is very important to them
and yeah so it's the local Oprah
structure is managed by Lockheed and the
satellites when you is belong to NASA
Thanks thanks for the talk it really
interesting to see fellow
astrophysicists here so what was the
background fluctuations you were talking
about so the noise from which you're
trying to disentangle your signal so the
noise is just so so in addition to these
high-energy atmospheric needed sorry
high energy astrophysical neutrinos
there are also neutrinos that are made
in air showers in the atmosphere and it
could be that you just happen to have
ended up in a year or ended up with a
series of over fluctuations where you
had ones that are very high energy just
by chance it can happen and that's the
thing you need to exclude when they look
at that they're there on the face of
them not distinguishable from
Astrophysical neutrinos we just do it we
can only make the distinction by energy
and angle
I was wondering what the reason was to
do this on South Pole is it only because
there's a lot of ice or is it also the
environment at the local atmosphere that
play a role so the main reason to do it
so you need a lot of you need a lot of
material so what you need a lot of water
or ice Isis has its own adventures it's
mechanically stable and once it's once
it's frozen everything had everything
everything becomes stable you don't have
to worry about your detail your detector
units imploding under the pressure once
it's become stable but the reason to it
at the South Pole specifically is
because it's a place that already has
communications in power and is sitting
on two and a half kilometers of ice
there's actually a consideration to it
to do it in Greenland could have also
been done but would have been much more
expensive and the station's already
there it's already being the extra power
budget to run ice cube is not that much
and so it's less expensive than it would
otherwise be
no more question come on one question no
maybe I'll ask a question too close I
don't know here all right um hello I
wonder if in this permanent a when you
collect the data I guess that there is a
certain uncertainty within the measuring
of the data you are doing the analysis
it's that come bring some noise in the
data itself the the method where you are
collecting that data so is how you are
measuring them the actual a methodology
of collecting the information so yeah so
the experiment itself does introduce
biases their trigger thresholds so the
detector is not read out unless there is
there a certain number of photons are
collected in a time period and so that
does introduce an energy threshold but
that's as important very low energies at
the high energies the biases are fairly
small but the data itself is also is
also noisy to the data itself our counts
of photons and they have statistical
fluctuations in them too and so for
example we can't reconstruct energies
exactly we can only give confidence
intervals that have basically 1 over
square root and noise in them
so I have a second question and it's
about open science do you release the
data and the packages so other teams can
double check or so my answer is almost
so we are so we are required so this is
funded by the US National Science
Foundation one of the conditions that
funding is that we do release the data
we do not release the raw data nor do we
actually release these tools and most of
that amazing may know the reason that
things are closed source is not usually
because they're so great it's because
the so we don't really have the funding
for a full-time data data release
manager who would actually go out there
and be available full time to support
people doing analyses on this other
experiments are different I'm like
that's fair me experiment I mentioned
before NASA actually provides a data
support team who are there only to
maintain only to maintain the tools and
provide user support on the outside so
we typically do is we provide these so
the day we don't actually fly the raw
data we provide these histograms that
used for analysis and so to the best of
our ability we provide the we provide
tools to reproduce exactly analysis that
was done but it's not necessarily
extendable to others but that is so our
goal is to release data we're not always
able to do so in a way that is easily
usable unfortunately
okay if there are no more questions
maybe we can break for lunch time I
think so thanks again yeah code one
that's one last shameless plug to sell
with you if you're interested in science
and you are local I would encourage you
in a few weeks there is no there is the
Berlin wide science open house called
the long enough Tennyson Shafton and
especially not to us off at the house
science campus are there a lot of events
like this their love there'll be a lot
of talks a lot of hands-on activities
for the kids if you have kids bring them
the one I love it and so yeah check this
out if you'd like i'm going to log an
activist and shuffle